hello everyone and welcome to another
video on python programming
in this video we will be learning about
the concept of regular expressions
now a regular expression is simply a
sequence of characters that defines a
search pattern
for example if you see this example here
you can see a symbol called the carrot
followed by p and then five periods
then an n and a dollar sign and what
this regex pattern does
is it's searching for a seven letter
string that starts with p
ends with n and has five characters in
between
let's look at this example now this is
a regex pattern that is looking for a
five character string
that starts with a ends with s and has
three characters in between
now if we had to match this with this
string with these strings as in
as i or test strings the first one would
not match because it's a three letter
string and we're looking for a five
character string
the second one would match because it's
a five character string that
ends with an s starts with an a and has
three characters in between
this will not match because whatever
pattern would do is it would find the
first
s and it would find that it the string
itself starts with an
a and it would say okay there are only
two characters between this first test
and this a and it would assume that this
is actually just
a four character string to actually
identify
two consecutive ss we would have to do
something special and what we would have
to do is
what we will see later on so again this
is the same example since this is case
insensitive capital a
uh is perfectly fine when we're
searching for this and it will also
match
this is this is obviously two words
and it's not a five character string so
this will not be a match
now the regex pattern or the regular
expression module in python
can be imported using this statement
import re now once we've done this
we can actually use the our regular
expression tools and methods
to do uh pattern recognition character
recognitions
and to identify different sequence of
characters in our strings
let's try to understand a bit more in
depth about regular expressions now
so what you're seeing here is one
variable called pattern which stores
something that looks like a regex and
another variable that stores our test
string called abus
now what we're going to do is we're
going to use the match method
of this module re and we're going to
check
whether this pattern or whatever we are
trying to search using this regex
is in fact does it match with our test
string
and what we're trying to look for is if
you see here very similar to what i just
showed you
a five character string that starts with
a and ends with s
so if you see our test string it indeed
is a match
and when we use this uh this command we
should get a perfect match
so we should be basically it should say
that search is successful if i execute
this
and this is what it does now if i change
the test string to
this now you will see that now this is
no longer
what we're looking for a five character
string with uh a
and starting with a and ending with s
and you will see that the search will be
unsuccessful
as you can see here now let's try to
understand
what exactly do we mean by uh when we
use
these different certain these special
symbols like for example this carrot or
this
dollar symbol um these are by the way
known as meta characters
and now we're going to look into all the
uh or most of the different meta
characters that are used in red x
so to put it simply meta characters are
simply characters that are interpreted
in a special way
by the regex search engine now here's a
list of meta characters
let's go through them one by one now the
square brackets
square bracket simply specifies the set
of characters that we wish to match
so we want to match some combination of
a b and c
it can be one a two a's three b's four
c's we are not looking at a specific
pattern we just want to know if a b
and c exists in any form in our string
so if we used it on a the string a
simply we would find one match because
the
letter a is found here ac would match
twice because we have a
and c present here in this string hey
jude
we will have no matches because a b and
c none of them are found here
and in this weird string we will have
actually one two
three four and five matches
so we would have five matches for this
uh this bigger string
because we have five instances of a b or
c
now let's use our e dot match to
do to actually search for this and to
see if we have our particular whatever
patterns that we're looking for
now in this input string this is just
some example string
um i'm going to test this i'm going to
match whether
my pattern that any of a b and c
is it actually found in this so let's
see what happens when i use re.match for
this
so the the format uh the syntax is
simply the regex pattern
and then comma whatever test string that
we have so
let's see what object gets created when
we try to do this
as you can see it's none even though you
might be wondering like i can see an
a over here i can see a c over here
re.match
actually gives us the result none
now if i try to do it on this test
string
which is slightly different instead of
the film titanic was at least in 1998
what i'm saying here is all film titanic
was at least in 1998.
now let's see if the r match works or
not
as you can see it actually does return
when i execute this it returns us an
object called
ie.match object with a span01 the span01
is basically telling us
that we have found a match between the
zeroth and the first character which is
basically this character a
which is what it has found and it's
saying that the match is indeed the
character a
from amongst these options so what this
is basically telling us
and what this means actually is that
the re.match method will only find
matches if they occur at the start of
the string being searched
once there is a space in in our bigger
string it will not search for whatever
comes after it
so what happened in the first instance
was it was actually only searching for
matches in this particular word
in my largest string and since it found
no match it basically gave us the result
none
which was not the case in the second
example because it found a match
immediately in the first letter a
now if we want to actually check the
whole thing what we would be
using is the re.search
as you can see here the re.search method
will actually check the whole string and
it will return us the first
instance where it finds a match now
let's see
this is the test string now and now
we're searching again for
our uh we're searching for a b and c any
any of these
um in our test string but we're going to
use re.search and not match so now if
you see
it returns us when i execute this it
returns us a match object again
but this time it's saying the span of 9
and 10. now the spine panel 9 and 10
actually exists over here this is the
ninth character and a itself for the
10th character
over here so what this basically is
telling us that the 10th character is
where we found a match
which was the letter a which was the
first instance of either a
or b or c in this whole string and this
is basically how re.search works
it will not only search the beginning of
the string but it will search the whole
string
and return us the first instance or
wherever we find
now what if we wanted to find out all
the instances
wherever a b and c were found and not
just the first instance
but in that case we would be using the
method find all over here
so when we use find all it will actually
return us each and every case
where it found a b or c and you might
not it won't
tell you the exact position but it will
tell you like
um so if i execute this you can see it
gives us a
a list with a c a and a and what this
basically means is it was looking for
the characters a
or b or c and it found a first and hence
this for the first item in the list
and then it found a c and then it found
two is successfully
so this is exact this is actually how
find all works where it will actually
find all the instances
of our regex pattern now that you've
seen how the square brackets work and
how the
re dot search and re dot match and re
dot find all
methods work now we're going to go
through all the other meta characters
that we saw above
so the period now period matches any
single character except the new line new
line is basically slash
n or a break now if you look at this
picture
what it's going to do is um
this expression basically saying that uh
do we have
um two characters like sets of two
characters in our string
so this is a single character string and
obviously a single character string
is not a double character string and
this expression this double dot
is basically uh asking us do we have two
characters present in our string
so if i had to match it with this a it
will obviously be a no match because
a is one character if we checked it with
ac it is a match because a
and c are two characters a c and d will
also give us only one match because it
will find a
c and then it will leave d as a single
character but when we check a c
d and e or this string in particular it
will find two matches because
it will consider a and c as one of the
matches and d and e as one of the
matches
so below is basically what we're doing
basically the same thing we're just
using rd dot search
for each of these different examples so
if i if you see when i use find all on
acde
and when i'm searching for a two
character match you will see that it
will return me a
c and d e as you can see here and
similarly for something like this it
will return me again
whatever like two character patterns it
finds successively
so the next symbol the next meta
character is the carrot symbol that
you've seen earlier
then the carrick symbol is basically
used to check if a string
starts with a certain character so if
you look at these two this picture if
you have two two expressions that we're
going to check over here
one is the one is checking if a is the
beginning of a string and
the other one will check if a
is the beginning of the string but is it
followed by b or not
so when we check this what you can see
is the first
string will be a match because it's the
only the character a and it will match
here as well because this
string starts with a but it will not
match here because this string starts
with b
now if i look at this particular
expression
you can see that um this is going to
search for
if the string starts with a and is
followed by a b so it will match in this
case because it does start with a and is
followed by a b but it will not match in
this case even though it starts with an
a
because it's not followed by a b so out
here is basically us using the ie.search
to basically find these patterns
the next symbol that we will come across
is the dollar symbol
so the dollar symbol that you can see
here is used to check if a string ends
with a certain character and we've
already seen how this is used
in one of the uh one of the earlier
examples so this is going to check
basically if so this expression will
check if the string ends with a
so this this string is basically the
character a so it will match
this also ends with a so it will match
and this particular string
does not end with a so it will not match
and we are going to do that using the re
dot search
over here so as you can see it finds a
match
in the first character itself here in
this case it finds a match in the last
character
but in cab there is no match so it
returns us a none
another example is of the meta
characters is star
so this is the symbol for star and this
what the star basically is used
is for checking if there are zero or
more occurrences
of the pattern to the left of it so now
if you see here
what this will check for is um is there
any form of
m and a that occurs before n and it's
very important to note
that the n has to follow the a in this
case
so let's look at these examples and what
will happen so if i checked it with m
and
n this is actually a match because n is
followed by
zero occurrences of m and a which is if
it might seem a little weird but it is
technically the truth
because uh the the star symbol checks
for not
doesn't check for the existence it just
checks for
if n occurs it must occur after an a
or the a should not be there itself in
this particular string so as you can see
here the n
occurs after an m and it's fine because
there is no a
now you will see when it will not work
so m a and n is obviously fine
m a uh m triple a n is also fine because
n
follows an a and there's an m here this
however
main will not match now why even though
we have m and a
and we have an n you see the n is
immediately followed by an
i is n follows an i immediately
or the n is preceded by an i immediately
and this is
a no match because our the strict
condition in the search is that n
must uh precede an a if the a exists
again in women it will match because n
follows an a
over here we're just going to use the id
dot search for these examples that we
saw over here in terms of code using the
re dot search
as you can see here finally we have the
next meta character
which is the plus symbol yes so the plus
symbol
matches one or more occurrences of the
pattern
left to it now this is very similar to
what we saw earlier in terms of the star
except now in the plus the key
difference is we're looking for one or
more occurrences
instead of zero or more occurrences that
we were looking for in the case of star
so when we say one or more occurrences
now
we need what is there to the left of the
plus sign
at zero no occurrence of it will not be
allowed or will not cause a match
so let's see now what we're going to do
here we're going to use the same
expression except we're going to replace
the star with the plus sign so now what
we're going to say is okay we need m and
a
at least one occurrence followed by an n
the all of these conditions have to be
met
so again if you took the first example m
and n this time it will be a no match
because there is no occurrence of an a
over here for preceding the n so it's a
no match
m a and n is a match because well this
is
this is perfectly fine m triple a and n
is also perfectly fine
but if you look at m a i and n much like
earlier the n
is uh preceded by an i and not an a so
there is no match
and again women is perfectly fine and we
basically execute the same thing through
the search function in this piece of
code the next meta character is the
question mark
the question mark symbol matches 0 or 1
occurrences of the pattern
to the left of it so let's see what this
does
so now we saw the star the star which
was zero or more occurrences of the
pattern to the left of it
we saw the plus which is one or more
occurrences of the pattern to the left
of it
now we will see the question mark which
is zero or one
only zero or only one and not zero or
more of one or more which was the
previous cases only zero and one or one
occurrences of the pattern to the left
of it
again we're going to see the same
expression except we're going to replace
the meta character with the question
mark
so now let's see what what happens when
we match so if you see here
m and n is a match because there is zero
occurrence of a
and one occurrence of m preceding n so
this is fine
this is also fine because there is one
eight occurrence of a and m
and then this pres followed by an n this
will not be fine because now we have
three occurrences of a
which is followed by an n we're only
looking for zero or one
this again main will be a no match for
the same reasons that we have already
gone through
and women will be a match again for the
same reasons
and we read through the same things
using the search function in this piece
of code
the next meta character is the braces
character now the braces character is
interesting because what we're going to
do is
we're going to see if there are so uh
this is
the typical syntax for a braces is an uh
brace
followed by some integer n comma integer
m
and then close braces so what this means
is we're looking for
at least n and at most m repetitions
of the pattern left of the braces let's
see through an example
if you see this expression we're looking
for at least two
and at most three occurrences of this
the character a
in our test strings so let's see what
happens in the first case
we have no matches in this case because
this part of the string contains only
one a
and even this part of the string only
contains one a we're looking for at
least two
and at most three this part will contain
one match the second the second example
because the second part of the string
actually contains
two a's for one uh two uh repetitions of
ace con
consecutively but this uh in the end
and in the third example you can see
both the strings actually contain
matches
so we get two matches because as you can
see here there's two a's here followed
by three a's here
now when we look at this particular
string let's look at what happens now
so what we're going to find is that this
thing is perfectly fine so we have two
occurrences of a
but now we have four occurrences of a
but what the
search engine is going to recognize is
these first three is and it's going to
see okay so there are three occurrences
of a
and i already have a match it's not
going to consider this fourth a
and the search it will just look at the
first three and then say okay there are
uh three a's and my my match is fine so
again there are two matches in this case
again we're going to use the search
function initially and you can see each
in each of the cases there is a match
except for the first case which is this
case
now let's see the find all option and
see what happens when we do the same
thing using find all
so when we use find all it basically
gives us each of the instances where the
match has occurred
in each of these lists now let's try to
use a slightly more uh complicated
example
where we combine different let's say
different meta characters
and we create a more sophisticated
expression that we want to search in our
test strings
so if you look at this expression what
we're looking for is
0-9 now a dash symbol is valid
in python using regex because what this
basically tells it
is that it's looking for either 0 one
two three four
so on until nine basically any of the
digits we're
looking for any of the digits from zero
to nine and we are going to
check if at least two and at most four
occurrences of digits
if they are there or not in our
particular code so let's see what are
the matches that happens when we use it
on test strings so if you use it on this
string
you can see it will find one match this
basically this particular part of the
string where it says one two three
so this is uh three occurrences of
digits so it's fine
now when we look at this whole string 12
and
whatever this is you will see this will
not find a match here
this obviously will not because these
are characters but if you look at
this part it will find matches in terms
of the first four and then
seven and three the next two one and two
again there are no matches because
there's only single occurrences of
digits we're looking for it at
at least two and at most four so if i
use a find all
you will see like what all it will
return so for the first
test string what is going to return me
is it's going to determine 1 2 and 3 as
you can see here
but now if you look at this test string
it's going to return me
12 it's going to return me 3 4 5 and 6
is going to return me 3 4 1 and 2 but
not 7 because we're looking for at least
2
and then it's going to return me 4 5 6
and 7 followed by 8 and 8
as you can see in this list over here
now if we use curly braces with only one
digit
it's basically telling the search engine
that we want exactly so many repetitions
of the
preceding uh whatever kind of expression
that we have
so when we do this example for uh for
example we're basically saying
that we want x followed by
a dash and the dash has to occur at
least three times
in our particular expression and then it
should be followed by an x again
which will not match in this case
because there are only two dashes and it
will match in this case because there
are exactly three dashes
and it will again not not match in this
case because there are four dashes
as you can see here none followed by an
object match followed by none
next we move on to the alternation um
the alternation meta character and as
the word suggests alternation is
basically looking for some alternate
form of a and b
so a should be followed by a b and uh
basically this pattern has to keep going
on so in the first string over here
this pattern will not match in the
second string over here
we will have a match because we at least
find an a even though there is no b
but this is to consider match because we
did find an a at least
over here we'll have uh three matches
because we have a followed by a b
followed by an a again so uh if we did a
reg expression for this
we would basically find these many
matches for each of these examples
the next meta character is the group now
a parenthesis
is basically used to group sub patterns
so let's look at an example to
understand what we mean
now if you look at this complicated
expression what this means
is that i want some form of x and z
the x and z have to occur together but
before that
what i want is some form of a following
b
following c some sort of alternation
between a b and c
so this part as you can see here is kept
in a parenthesis because i want this
whole condition
to basically occur before i find in x
and z
so let's look at what happens here in
the first case we don't have
a match because uh there this basically
this parenthesis condition is not being
met
the x and z is preceded by a space or
basically the a and b
is preceded is followed by a space so if
this space didn't occur we would
actually find a match
as you can see in the next example here
you can see a and b occur
basically this uh initial condition is
met followed by x and z so there is
a one match so it's fine for us now if
you look at this
slightly more a trickier one what you
can see
is we have two matches in this case
first in a followed by x and z
and then we have c a and b now
this is perfectly fine because we we are
looking for a b
followed by an x and z we're looking for
either of these things
we're looking for some form of
alternation of these things followed by
an x and z
and we can get that over here we get b
followed by an x and z
so you'll get two matches in this case
now let's go through the concept of
grouping constructs now that you've seen
many meta characters you've seen how
parenthesis works
let's look at grouping constructs so
grouping constructs break up a regex in
python into
sub expressions or groups and this
serves two purposes one is a grouping
part which basically says that a group
represents a single syntactic entity
and any additional meta characters apply
to the entire group as a unit
and then there is a capturing part which
basically tells us that some grouping
constructs also capture the portion of
the search string that matches the sub
expression in the group you can retrieve
captured matches later through several
different mechanisms so
let's look at uh basically what we mean
by this example over here
so if you see this this expression has a
plus sign
so we're looking for uh as you know a
plus looks for one or more occurrence
so this will basically check for one or
more occurrence of the character r
only because there's no parenthesis as
in this example
so this plus is next to an r and it's
going to
check for basically whether one or more
occurrence of
r happens uh preceding b and a
but if we actually put b a and r in a
parent thesis followed by plus
it will actually check for the entire
string b a r and it will check one or
more occurrences of b a r together
so if you look at these two examples
when we use this uh
on these examples you can see that these
are fine like these matches are fine
but if i used this uh parent thesis
then these would be the acceptable
matches and like ba
triple r would not be a match if i use
parenthesis uh as you can see here
so this is how grouping constructs work
and how parenthesis work
so let's look at some other examples so
what this will do is
f o o has to be optionally
followed by bar and bar must exist
together and this is because we have a
question mark here
this question mark symbol tells us that
it should be 0 or 1 occurrences
similarly this particular completed
expression is checking for one or more
occurrences of whatever we saw earlier
basically this whole thing is followed
by a plus so we're looking for this
whole sequence
for one or more occurrences of it cow is
simply just cow we're looking for this
pattern
and this is going to check for
zero or one occurrence of c or w because
of the existence of the question mark
for uh preceded by
the parenthesis if getting your learning
started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now that you know the basics of regular
expressions
let's continue our discussion with
special sequences now in an earlier
video on strings you might have
encountered
what is an escape sequence and how we
use the backslash character to generate
these escape sequences
and an escape sequence is basically if
you remember
something that we use to either give
certain special meaning to characters
that are otherwise ordinary
or it is used to remove the special
meaning that are inherently present in
certain characters
that we call meta characters so let's
look at what special sequences are
in relation to regular expressions so
the first one we're going to look at is
the backslash capital a which is used to
match if specified characters are at the
present
are present at the start of a string so
out here if you can see
we are checking if the word d
is present in these two strings so we
would get a match in the first case over
here because this starts with the word d
but in the second case we won't get a
match and this is how we're going to
check it
for the same thing using the find all
function
so if you see in the first case it gives
us it returns us an
object because we do find d in the
beginning of the string
in the second case we get us empties
list because the string does not start
with the word t
now the next one that we'll look at is
backslash b
small b now this is used to match if
specified characters at the beginning or
the end of a word
so when you use backslash small b and
then you follow it up with whatever
you're looking for
it would look for the that particular
those particular characters or that
pattern
if it exists in the beginning of a word
in a string
so if you look at the first example it
starts with f double o
and in the second example you see this
portion of the
string or this word is actually also
starting with f double o so it will also
match
however in this string which is very
similar to the second one
we don't have a space between a and f
and it's basically one word so this does
not start with f double o but it
actually starts with afo
and it won't match as you can see here
now similarly if we wanted to check if
something exists in the back of a string
at the end of a string we type what we
want to search for first
and then we follow it with a backslash
small b and
then if you see here it will match in
this first case it will
match in the second case because this
part of the string ends with f double o
but it will not match in this case
because well we removed the space so now
this whole thing becomes a
the string that we're looking for and it
does not end with fw anymore
and this is basically us just checking
in through the find all function
now the next scale the next special
sequence that we will be looking at
is the slash capital b which is
basically the opposite of what we just
saw
this matches only if the specified
characters are not at the beginning or
the end of a word
so if you see here this is checking if f
double o is not at the beginning
of these strings so in this case there
will be a no match
in this case also it will be a no match
and this third case there will be a
match
similarly if we wanted to see if
something does not end with
a particular string we would type that
whatever pattern we are looking for
followed by a backslash capital b and
then we can use the final function to
generate us lists wherever we find such
objects find such matches in our
particular test strings
like we have done over here so the next
one that we're going to look at is the
backslash
small d and this matches any decimal
digit which is equivalent to doing a
square brackets
0-9 as you've seen you must have seen
earlier so if we did a square bracket
0-9 and we
did a search or a find all or a match it
would look for
any of the digits between 0 and 9. so a
similar thing can be done using a
special sequence backslash small d
so as you can see there will be three
matches in this case because one two and
three digits exist
whereas in this case for the word python
there will be no matches
so these are certain examples where we
are doing the same thing using the
backslash d
now we have another one which is the
backslash capital d and this is just
basically the opposite
it matches for any non-decimal digits
it's also equivalent to typing
a carrot inside uh square brackets with
0-9
which if you remember from the previous
video is basically
asking us to check for anything that is
not
the digit 0-9 so this is basically we're
going to check in these two strings if
there is
no digits and no non-decimal digits so
if you see here we will
find three matches a b and the double
double inverted
commas and in the second string we will
find no matches because
this is fully just digits next we have
backslash small s
now this matches where a string contains
any white space character
so this is equal to doing a check for
all of these
so this is like backslash small t is a
check for tab space backslash small
n is a check for break line and then
backslash r
black slash f backslash b uh are their
own
uh checks for uh different sorts of
white space characters
that you can see by just looking it up
honestly but yeah so if you simply do a
backslash s
it would actually be the equivalent of
searching for any of these
white space white space characters that
we generate
so if you see here when we do a
backslash s on this string
you can see that there is one space over
here so it will match it will give us
one match because there is one white
space
which is just the normal space here and
in the second example there is no match
because there is no white space here
similarly slash capital s now as you
might have noticed
is basically checking for a string which
does not matches in a string wherever
there is no white space characters
so it's basically the same as doing
carrot slash t slash n slash
r f slash v in a square brackets so this
is basically a simpler way of doing
uh the same thing using square brackets
in a carrot symbol
so if you see this expression backslash
capital s
now we're looking at uh a space b so
over here if you see
it will match for all the non spaces so
it's going to match for a and b
so we're going to get two matches here
whereas an empty string does not contain
well it does not contain any non-white
space character since an empty spring
is basically a white space character on
its own so this would be this will give
us a no match
so the next special sequence that we're
going to look at is the backslash small
w
uh this matches any alphanumeric
character which is the equivalent of
doing a to z
in small and then capital a to z and 0
to 9 for
and also an underscore check in square
brackets um
it's also it's important to note that
the underscore is considered an alpha
minimic character hence why we include
it over here
but yeah this is the backslash w small w
which basically checks for any
alphanumeric character and matches it in
a string
so if you see in this first case it will
find three matches at one
two and also at the letter c these
others are not alphanumeric characters
whereas in this string none of these are
alphanumeric characters so we will get
no match
again much like the other examples there
is a capital there's a backslash capital
w which will check for any
non-alphanumeric character
and it's the equivalent of doing
whatever we did before in uh
in the square brackets just with a
preceded by a carrot sign so if you see
here
we have this string where we have a
bunch of characters
well yeah only one of them this uh
percentage symbol is a non-alphanumeric
character so we will get
one match over here but in this case in
the string python we will get no matches
because they are all
alphanumeric characters which is doing
the same thing here with a bunch of
different examples using the find all
function
now the backslash capital z matches if
the specified characters are at the end
of a string
now don't confuse this with uh backslash
small b plus the backslash small b
checks for a string and it checks each
and every word in the string
individually and checks if so if any of
the words ends with a particular thing
or starts with a particular thing but it
checks each word individually
but in this case the backslash capital z
will check the string only and not
each word so if you see the difference
here in
when you use capital backslash capital z
it will match in this first example but
it won't match for the next two
but if you used a backslash small b over
here
it would actually match not only the
first example here but it will also
match
in the second example because it would
check this word individually and it will
find out that yeah there is a match here
as well
so it would actually match in the second
example as well so yeah this was it on
regular expressions and with this we
will conclude our discussion
uh on regular expressions i hope you
learned something from this video
and as always do like and subscribe to
our channel and
share it with your friends so we can
reach more more learners such as
yourself
once again thank you and i hope to see
you again in the next video
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here